I was born and raised in the city of
Chicago and so I was looking for a small
liberal arts college and I went to a
college counselor and she happened to be
representing Hillsdale College and
obviously sold me on Hillsdale following
graduation I got a job in st. Clair
Shores which is outside Detroit and
taught lower elementary there for
several years I grew up in the small
town of reading Michigan twelve miles
from Hillsdale I was thinking of going
to college and I happened to be playing
baseball you know at the Hillsdale
fairgrounds the football coach at
Hillsdale College was there they said
why don't you come up the hills don't go
to school basically at that time I
wasn't flush with money and I said I
don't know as I can afford it he said
well coming up football practice maybe
we can help you out I say business in
Hillsdale there was a professor Larry
Taylor who ran a seminars for business
one of those seminars was a gentleman
from consumers power he invited me to
come in for an interview and I went to
work for consumers right on a graduation
I volunteered for the draft that fall
when it gave out the assignments I was
going to Korea so I had a big party that
night so I went to Korean spent 15
months there I went back to work for
consumers and one of my assignments was
in the East Detroit area but I was
unexpensive come and going out to dinner
why not go out to dinner with somebody
you know and you know friend didn't have
nice time till I called her and she said
yes and he must had a good time because
he did call me again and again I finally
got the nerve to kiss her so I kissed
her you know she said you're just really
a good friendship I've been a member for
25 years with heels our Garden Club
which is a nonprofit organization and I
think we have up to like 50 members we
have an interest in hosts of college
we've been members of the president's
club for a number of the earth we like
to take in some of the sporting events
and some of our contributions in the
past have been designated for those
activities
I came to Hillsdale and I notice it's
called the scholarship the title but
somebody help me I don't know what it
was and it's just a way of giving back
this has been a major part of my life
as a student and because we ended up
spending many many years here it
continues to be a very special part of
my life I feel honored
you
you